Vendredi 13 avril 1945,
l'Amérique est pétrifiée.
Franklin Roosevelt,
le président des États-Unis,
vient de mourir
alors que la Deuxième Guerre mondiale
n'est toujours pas terminée.
Roosevelt
était le grand artisan de la paix.
Plus que nul autre,
il incarnait l'espoir de voir
se reconstruire le monde
sur des bases meilleures.
Alors que la foule regarde
en silence passer le cortège funèbre,
la planète entière
se pose une question.
Sans Roosevelt,
Occidentaux et Soviétiques
parviendront-ils à s'entendre ?
Et à construire une paix durable ?
12 avril 1945,
Washington, à la Maison Blanche.
Trois heures après la mort de Roosevelt,
Harry Truman devient
le nouveau président des États-Unis.
Il fait son entrée en scène
dans un monde en plein chaos.
En ce mois d'avril 1945,
l'Amérique est toujours en guerre
contre Hitler et contre les Japonais.
Pour ne rien simplifier,
cela fait à peine trois mois que
Truman est vice-président.
Et rien ne le prédestinait
vraiment à devenir
le nouveau président des États-Unis.
C'est un ancien vendeur
de chemises et de cravates du Missouri.
Il s'est lancé
dans la politique sur le tard
et a été élu sénateur pour la
la première fois dix ans auparavant.
Si Roosevelt
l'a choisi comme vice-président,
ce n'est pas pour ses compétences.
Il l'a pris pour des considérations
totalement électorales,
tout en pensant qu'il était nul,
ce qui se fait beaucoup aux États-Unis.
Quand on choisit le vice-président,
ce n'est pas forcément
pour son intelligence,
parce que c'est souvent lui
qui va amener des votes
des endroits dont on a besoin.
En l'espace d'une journée,
l'ancien commerçant du Missouri
se retrouve donc propulsé à la tête
de la première puissance mondiale.
Lui-même est sidéré et ne s'en cache pas.
À la une de la presse,
des journalistes racontent
ce que Truman leur a confié.
Les gars, si vous priez,
priez pour moi.
Je ne sais pas si une botte
de foin vous est déjà tombée dessus,
mais quand on m'a dit
ce qui était arrivé hier,
j'ai eu l'impression que la lune,
les étoiles et toutes les planètes
m'étaient tombé dessus.
Aujourd'hui encore,
le petit-fils du président Truman,
se souvient que son grand-père
n'a jamais cherché à faire semblant
d'être l'homme de la situation.
Il n'était pas préparé à tout ça.
Il disait " il doit y avoir un million de
personnes plus qualifiées que moi
pour exercer cette fonction.
C'est sur moi que c'est tombé,
alors je vais faire tout
ce qu'il faut pour être à la hauteur".
C'était le genre d'homme auquel
on donnait un boulot et qui le faisait.
La tâche s'annonce rude.
Il faut reconstruire le monde
de demain et lui donner des bases solides.
Mais Truman n'a aucune
connaissance en politique internationale.
Durant les trois mois
de sa vice-présidence,
Roosevelt ne l'a rencontré
que deux fois en tête à tête.
Truman n'a été mis au courant de rien.
Je trouve que mon grand-père a eu tort
de ne pas l'intégrer un peu plus.
Il était parfaitement conscient
de la dégradation de ses forces,
mais je crois
qu'il n'avait plus assez d'énergie
pour associer Truman à ses décisions
et passer le relais.
Deux mois avant de mourir,
Roosevelt avait rencontré
Staline et Churchill à Yalta.
C'est là, en Crimée, que les trois grands
avaient jeté les bases de la future paix.
Les accords scellés
étaient complexes et plein d'ambiguïtés.
Chacun des alliés
ayant joué sa propre partie.
De toutes ces discussions,
Truman a été tenu à l'écart.
Il doit se mettre à jour
sur tous les dossiers.
C'est un pragmatique
et un gros travailleur.
Alors il enchaîne
les briefings avec ses conseillers.
Ce travail acharné suffira-t-il ?
Le petit marchand de cravates du Missouri
parviendra-t-il à faire
le poids face au redoutable Staline ?
Un mois après l'arrivée
de Truman à la tète de la Maison Blanche,
les Alliés gagnent la guerre en Europe.
Sur tout le continent,
les peuples exultent.
À Londres,
devant Buckingham Palace,
une marée humaine
est venue acclamer Winston Churchill.
Le Premier ministre britannique
est célébré en héros.
Pourtant malgré ce moment d'euphorie,
Churchill a les traits tirés.
Le sourire à ses lèvres
a quelque chose de forcé.
Dans ses mémoires, il écrit :
Las, épuisé,
appauvri mais toujours intrépide
et désormais triomphant.
Nous connûmes
un moment qui touchait au sublime.
Pourtant,
peu de cœurs devaient être
plus dévorés d'inquiétude que le mien.
Que peut-il y avoir
d'aussi grave pour tenir un tel moment ?
Le problème pour Churchill
s'appelle Staline.
Maintenant que
la guerre est gagnée en Europe,
le Britannique est persuadé
que Staline va en profiter
pour instaurer
des régimes communistes
partout où il le pourra.
Déjà, contrairement
aux engagements pris à Yalta,
le leader soviétique a installé
un régime communiste en Roumanie.
En Pologne,
six ministres non-communistes
sont bien entrés au gouvernement,
mais ils ont chaque jour
un peu moins de pouvoir.
Staline voulait que
toute l'Europe devienne communiste.
C'était par idéologie,
mais c'était aussi parce que c'était
un homme avec une mentalité d'empereur,
un dictateur
avec une mentalité d'empereur.
Le Premier ministre britannique
tente alors de mettre Truman en garde.
Le tout nouveau
président américain ne veut rien savoir.
Pour l'heure,
Truman s'est fixé comme cap
de respecter
les engagements pris par Roosevelt.
Il n'est pas disposé
à entendre quoi que ce soit
contre son allié communiste.
Churchill n'a plus qu'à espérer
que Truman ouvre les yeux par lui-même.
L'occasion va bientôt lui en être donnée.
16 juillet 1945, aéroport de Berlin.
L'avion du Président américain
vient tout juste d'atterrir.
Truman se rend en Europe
pour participer à une conférence de paix.
À cette occasion,
il va enfin rencontrer ses alliés
et se faire sa propre idée sur eux.
Les discussions
doivent avoir lieu à Potsdam,
à quelques kilomètres de Berlin.
Pour s'y rendre,
Truman traverse l'ex-capitale du Reich.
Berlin n'est plus qu'un champ de ruines.
Seuls quelques rares
passants errent, hagards.
Ce spectacle de désolation
bouleverse Truman
et le poussera à vouloir aider
l'Allemagne à se relever.
Le soir, dans son journal, il écrit :
Jamais je n'avais vu un spectacle
plus désolant ni plus affligeant.
Nous avons vu
des vieillards, des vieilles femmes,
des jeunes femmes
emportant vers nulle part
ce qu'ils pouvaient
et ce qu'il restait de leurs biens.
La conférence s'ouvre le lendemain,
le 17 juillet.
Ici, au château de Cecilienhof,
c'est l'unique fois où Staline,
Truman et Churchill
se rencontreront tous ensemble.
Comme Truman s'y attendait,
Churchill, lui, semble charmant.
Quant à Staline,
ses conseillers ne cessent de lui
répéter qu'on peut lui faire confiance.
Pourtant, très vite,
le nouveau président
prend la mesure de l'homme
avec lequel il va devoir négocier.
Je peux traiter avec Staline.
Il est honnête
mais malin comme le diable.
De son côté, Staline,
ne se méfie aucunement de Truman.
Pour lui,
il reste un petit boutiquier du Missouri.
Staline a peu de renseignements sur lui
car, comme il ne jouait aucun rôle,
ses espions
ne lui ont pas vraiment parlé de lui
et ce qui lui en avait dit
lui avait laissé prévoir
que c'était quelqu'un de pas important,
de mou et qu'on allait pouvoir
lui faire accepter n'importe quoi.
Or, quand Truman dit non, c'est non.
Car contre toute attente,
malgré son peu d'expérience,
le président américain
sait se montrer ferme.
Il n'est nullement
impressionné par Staline.
Question de caractère sans doute,
mais pas seulement.
Truman se sent en position de force
car il attend une information
qui pourrait faire de lui
l'homme le plus puissant de la planète.
Au même instant, aux États-Unis,
un événement
ultrasecret est en préparation.
Alors qu'il négocie,
le président américain
attend des nouvelles avec impatience.
Au deuxième jour des négociations,
enfin,
il reçoit un télégramme en langage codé.
Le docteur vient
de revenir enthousiaste et confiant
sur le fait que le petit garçon
est aussi costaud que son grand frère.
La lumière dans ses yeux
est visible d'ici à High Hold
et j'aurais pu entendre ses cris
d'ici à ma ferme.
Ce petit garçon en question,
Little Boy, c'est la bombe atomique.
Depuis quatre ans,
dans le plus grand secret,
les meilleurs savants de la planète,
travaillent à mettre au point
ce qui semble être l'arme absolue.
Nom de code de l'opération : Trinity.
Le premier essai atomique
de l'histoire est un succès total.
La puissance de l'explosion
est équivalente à 21 kilotonnes de TNT.
Jamais un tel pouvoir
de dévastation n'a été atteint.
Une seule arme a désormais le pouvoir
d'anéantir l'humanité toute entière.
Après quelques hésitations,
Truman finit par prévenir Staline.
C'est une mauvaise nouvelle,
bien entendu.
Ca veut dire que désormais,
l'Union soviétique
va se trouver en situation d'infériorité.
Tout le monde guettait
la réaction de Staline.
Et Staline,
qui est un très bon comédien,
dit :
"ah bon, vous avez une bombe puissante ?"
"Je vous félicite et j'espère que
vous l'utiliserez contre le Japon".
Staline
était-il vraiment dans l'ignorance ?
Malgré les mesures de protection
drastiques prises par les Américains,
les Russes sont parvenus à introduire
des espions sur la base de Los Alamos
où s'élabore la bombe atomique.
Parmi eux,
Klaus Fuchs.
Ce physicien allemand a fui le nazisme.
Fuchs est aussi
un espion à la solde des Soviétiques,
car c'est un communiste convaincu.
Depuis deux ans,
le scientifique livre aux Russes
tous les plans de la bombe américaine.
Grâce à ces renseignements,
les Soviétiques ont commencé à
développer leur propre arme nucléaire.
Malgré cela, le 24 juillet,
lorsque Staline apprend
que la bombe
américaine est désormais au point,
il devient nerveux.
Staline ne déteste rien
tant que se sentir vulnérable.
Il a convoqué les gens
qui se trouvaient à Potsdam,
et il a demandé
de transmettre aux scientifiques
et à tous ceux
qui travaillaient sur le projet atomique,
qu'il voulait qu'on accélère au maximum
la création
de la bombe atomique soviétique.
Cette bombe va devenir
une obsession pour Staline.
Tant qu'il n'aura pas
sa propre arme atomique,
le généralissime ne se sentira pas
en confiance face aux Américains.
Les relations avec Truman
vont alors commencer à se gripper.
Potsdam va aussi
être le théâtre d'une autre déflagration.
Au beau milieu de la conférence,
Churchill quitte la table des négociations
pour se rendre à Londres où il doit
attendre le résultat des élections.
En démocrate convaincu,
le Premier ministre britannique
a remis son mandat en jeu.
Depuis des semaines,
alors qu'il est en campagne,
il est acclamé dans toute l'Angleterre.
Mais au matin des élections,
à l'aube,
le Britannique a un mauvais pressentiment.
Je me réveillais soudain comme si l'on
m'avait planté un couteau de poignard
et j'ai ressenti
une douleur presque physique.
Le pouvoir de façonner
le futur me serait refusé.
L'intuition de Churchill était la bonne.
À la stupéfaction générale,
il n'est pas réélu.
Au héros de la guerre,
les Britanniques préfèrent un homme neuf.
Le leader travailliste Clement Attlee.
Au lendemain de sa victoire,
Attlee se glisse dans le fauteuil,
encore chaud, de Churchill.
Autour de la table, chacun
a l'impression d'une erreur de casting.
Clement Attlee, c'est quelqu'un
qui a l'air vraiment insignifiant.
Churchill disait
" un mouton déguisé en mouton ".
Ou bien une voiture vide
s'arrête devant Downing Street
et le major Attlee en descend.
Un homme modeste
et qui a de bonnes raisons de l'être etc.
Et là,
Staline est totalement déconcerté
parce qu'il était convaincu
que Churchill avait fait tout ce
qu'il fallait pour truquer les élections.
Parce que pour Staline,
c'est ce que fait tout politicien
qui est digne de son poste.
Face à un Attlee
un peu perdu et un peu gauche,
Staline prend les choses en main.
Il est le dernier
des trois géants de Yalta.
Désormais, avec Attlee, la Grande-Bretagne
est sur le banc de touche.
Le monde ne compte plus que
deux superpuissances
les États-Unis et l'Union soviétique.
Truman et Staline
se retrouvent face à face.
Très vite, les désaccords qui existent
entre les deux hommes vont se durcir
et se transformer
en de vraies oppositions.
Cinq jours après Potsdam,
Truman prend une décision
qui sera lourde de conséquences.
Les États-Unis vont utiliser
la bombe atomique contre le Japon.
La tension avec Staline
va aussitôt monter d'un cran.
6 août 1945,
aux premières heures du matin,
le bombardier américain Enola Gay
s'envole vers l'archipel nippon.
À 8 h 15,
Little Boy est largué sur Hiroshima.
Un gigantesque champignon
atomique s'élève au-dessus de la ville.
La température
au sol atteint 4 000 degrés.
70 000 personnes sont tuées sur le coup.
La ville n'est plus qu'un
désert de cendres et de poussière.
Trois jours plus tard,
le 9 août,
c'est au tour de Nagasaki d'être bombardé.
Le monde entier est sous le choc.
Pour Staline,
la bombe atomique est une provocation.
Il est persuadé que Truman
cherche à l'impressionner.
Il ne comprend pas que
l'Amérique ait largué ses bombes
alors que le 8 août,
comme elle s'y était engagée,
l'Union soviétique était entrée en guerre
contre le Japon aux côtés des États-Unis.
Pour nous,
le message envoyé par les États-Unis
était clairement que l'utilisation
de la bombe atomique contre le Japon
n'avait pas pour but de remporter
une victoire rapide contre les Japonais,
mais de faire peur à l'Union soviétique
afin de pouvoir dicter
les conditions américaines.
À l'évidence,
Truman a voulu
terminer la guerre au plus vite
et épargner des vies américaines.
Mais c'est aussi clairement
un message envoyé à Staline.
Car Truman entend bien lui faire savoir
que désormais, il est le maître du jeu.
Dès lors,
Staline veut savoir de quelle marge
de manœuvre il dispose face à Truman,
alors il va le tester.
À Yalta,
Staline s'était vu promettre
des territoires en échange
de son entrée en guerre contre le Japon.
L'île de Sakhaline,
les Kouriles, d'Irène et Port Arthur,
et une ligne de chemin de fer
en Mandchourie.
Mais Staline demande désormais,
en plus, à occuper l'île d'Hokkaido.
Dans un télégramme envoyé à Truman,
le généralissime explique.
" L'opinion publique russe
apprécierait que nos troupes "
" reçoivent une zone d'occupation
dans une partie de l'archipel ".
" Elle serait gravement offensée
dans le cas contraire ".
" J'espère que mes modestes
requêtes seront satisfaites ".
Puis il se ravise et rajoute
de façon manuscrite.
" Ne rencontreront pas d'objection ".
Le président américain est ulcéré.
Sa réponse est sans détour.
C'est non.
Un point c'est tout.
Grand-père attendait des gens
qu'ils soient droits et honnêtes.
Il était comme ça
et attendait en retour
que les gens
soient loyaux et francs avec lui.
Quand il a découvert
que ce n'était pas le cas
et que Staline
cherchait à profiter de lui,
il a commencé à négocier avec lui
d'une manière beaucoup plus rude.
Staline aussi a décidé
de passer à la vitesse supérieure.
Il va pousser son avantage en Europe.
Élections truquées, coups de force.
Partout où il le peut,
Staline impose des régimes communistes.
La Pologne, la Tchécoslovaquie,
la Hongrie et la Bulgarie
sont en passe de tomber
dans l'escarcelle soviétique.
Cette stalinisation rampante
de l'Europe inquiète Truman.
Mais le président américain est
encore hésitant sur la conduite à tenir.
Le télégramme qui atterrit sur son bureau
le 22 février 1946, va tout changer.
Son auteur,
George Kennan,
un simple diplomate
alors en poste à Moscou.
Kennan a eu le temps d'observer
le fonctionnement de Staline.
Il a compris qu'il voulait
faire main basse sur l'Europe de l'Est
et il a la conviction
que la seule façon de l'en empêcher
est de faire preuve de fermeté.
Dans un long télégramme
envoyé à Washington,
il décrit le mode
de fonctionnement soviétique.
Le Kremlin a
une attitude névrotique
à l'égard des affaires du monde,
qui lui vient de son instinct russe
d'insécurité permanent.
Les Russes sont imperméables
à la logique de raison
et très sensible à la logique de la force.
Kennan explique qu'il est inutile
de chercher à rassurer Staline
De toute façon,
Staline ne peut pas être rassuré,
ne veut pas être rassuré puisque
ça lui permet de justifier la dictature.
Mais en revanche,
soyons fermes face à Staline
parce qu'il comprend le rapport de force
et dès que les Occidentaux sont fermes,
Staline est prêt à se retirer.
L'analyse de Kennan
confirme tout ce que pressentait
intuitivement le président américain.
Dès lors, le changement de pied est total.
Truman se sépare
des anciens conseillers de Roosevelt,
jugés trop mous à l'égard
de l'Union soviétique,
et promeut des hommes neufs.
Dans la foulée,
Kennan est appelé à la Maison Blanche
en tant que conseiller spécial.
Reste une difficulté pour Truman,
faire comprendre à l'opinion publique
américaine ce revirement.
L'opération s'annonce délicate
car aux yeux des Américains,
Staline est le grand allié.
Celui qui a permis
de gagner la guerre contre Hitler.
La presse n'a eu de cesse
de le présenter en héros.
Ils ont subi quatre années
de propagande de guerre
qui leur montre Staline
comme l'ami des petits enfants
et le meilleur allié des États-Unis
grâce auquel on va gagner la guerre.
Cette propagande
a parfaitement réussi.
Staline est également
très populaire aux États-Unis.
Le président américain a alors une idée.
Il va se servir
de l'ancien Premier ministre britannique
et le laisser annoncer
lui-même la mauvaise nouvelle.
Churchill jouit
d'un prestige considérable.
Personne n'osera
mettre sa parole en doute.
Et puis,
l'ancien Premier ministre britannique
sera sûrement ravi
de venir aux États-Unis.
Depuis sa défaite aux élections,
il traverse une période
de dépression profonde.
Ce 5 mars 1946,
toute la petite ville
de Fulton, dans le Missouri,
a sorti les drapeaux pour
accueillir l'ancien Premier ministre.
Il fait un soleil radieux.
Truman,
qui accueille Churchill dans son fief,
est tout sourire.
Le président américain sait que le
Britannique s'apprête à lâcher une bombe,
mais il se gardera bien
de dire qu'il était au courant.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
à l'université de Fulton,
Churchill prononce un discours
qui va tétaniser l'assistance
et secouer le monde entier.
From stettin in the Baltic
to Trieste in the Adriatique
an iron curtain has fallen
on the continent.
Le discours
du rideau de fer provoque un tollé
Les Américains sont choqués.
Staline, leur grand ami.
C'était stratégiquement
assez habile de la part de Truman
de laisser Churchill prendre la parole
et d'employer cette expression
de rideau de fer,
parce que ça montrait
aussi à l'opinion américaine
et à l'opinion mondiale
que ce revirement
de la politique américaine
n'était pas uniquement le fait de Truman
ou de quelques conseillers isolés,
mais qu'une personnalité
aussi importante que Churchill
allait dans le sens
du président américain.
Bientôt,
les Américains qui admiraient Staline
vont le considérer
comme un dangereux tyran.
En URSS,
le discours de Fulton
passe pour un coup
de poignard dans le dos.
Staline est furieux.
Les intellectuels
et les proches du Kremlin
sont vent debout contre Churchill.
Churchill était l'ennemi
juré de notre pays.
Il était le leader le plus
antisoviétique de l'Ouest du monde.
Il a passé toute sa vie à faire
des mauvais coups à l'Union soviétique.
Désormais, les pays européens
sont contraints de choisir leur camp,
celui du communisme ou du capitalisme.
Dans cette course
pour se partager le monde,
Staline a une longueur d'avance.
Il a déjà mis la main sur
les pays d'Europe de l'Est
et gagne du terrain à l'Ouest.
En France et en Italie,
des ministres communistes
ont fait leur entrée au gouvernement.
Jusqu'où Staline va-t-il étendre
sa sphère d'influence ?
La France révolutionnaire de 1792.
La question hante Truman
et le président américain a bien compris
que dans ce bras de fer
qui l'oppose aux Soviétiques,
il avait contre lui un adversaire
de poids qui est la pauvreté.
Près de deux ans après la fin de
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale,
l'Europe ne s'est toujours pas relevée.
Le Vieux Continent est au bord du chaos.
Truman a parfaitement conscience que
cette misère fait le lit du communisme.
Mais avant d'agir,
il a besoin d'avoir
une vue claire de la situation.
Au début de l'année 1947,
Truman dépêche
en Europe Mike Mansfield.
Ce sénateur du Montana
a pour mission d'évaluer la situation.
Son rapport est effrayant.
Dans tous les pays visités,
il y a des cas évidents de malnutrition,
de tuberculose et de maladies.
En Italie,
la majorité de la population subsiste
grâce à des rations quotidiennes de pain
allant de 75 à 125 grammes.
Elle ne mange pratiquement rien d'autre.
À la lecture de ce rapport,
Truman acquiert une conviction.
S'il ne vient pas en aide aux Européens,
il laissera le champ libre
à Staline sur le continent.
Truman décide alors
d'un plan de sauvetage de l'Europe
confié au général George Marshall,
le nouveau secrétaire d'État américain.
Matières premières, machines-outils,
des tonnes de matériel sont acheminées
de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique.
Derrière son aspect généreux,
le plan Marshall
est aussi vital pour les États-Unis,
qui ont besoin de relancer leur économie.
C'était aussi une manière
de redonner vigueur au commerce américain.
Car vous ne pouvez pas
être riche tout seul dans le monde,
il faut que vous ayez
des partenaires qui sont riches.
Par conséquent, si les États-Unis,
qui avaient tiré profit de la guerre,
ne pouvaient pas
commercer avec d'autres pays
parce que les autres pays
n'avaient pas les moyens d'acheter,
ça voulait dire que
la richesse des États-Unis déclinerait.
Le Plan Marshall est également une arme
politique destinée à déstabiliser Staline,
car l'aide américaine
est offerte à tous les pays européens,
y compris les pays de l'Est.
Et bien sûr,
les pays de l'Est qui sont
sous la tutelle de l'Union soviétique
en ont aussi beaucoup besoin.
La Tchécoslovaquie, la Pologne,
à qui le plan Marshall est proposé.
Mais qu'est ce qui va l'emporter ?
C'est la méfiance idéologique.
Le plan Marshall était perçu
comme le plan
d'asservissement de l'Europe de l'Ouest
par les impérialistes américains.
Tout ça était inacceptable pour Staline.
Les pays de l'Est
tentés par l'aide américaine
sont sommés de rentrer dans le rang.
Seize pays au total
entrent dans le plan Marshall.
Tous à l'Ouest.
La France, le Royaume-Uni et l'Italie
sont les plus gros bénéficiaires.
Au milieu de l'année 1947, le rideau
de fer de Churchill est devenu une réalité
Une ville va faire les frais
des nouveaux rapports de forces
entre Occidentaux et Soviétiques.
Berlin.
La capitale allemande est située en plein
cœur de la zone d'occupation soviétique.
Mais la ville elle-même est occupée
par les quatre puissances alliées,
États-Unis,
Grande-Bretagne,
France et URSS.
Ensemble, toutes doivent remettre
l'Allemagne sur pied.
Mais les alliés ne sont pas
d'accord sur la marche à suivre.
La priorité pour les Soviétiques
est d'obtenir leurs réparations de guerre,
car l'URSS est ruinée.
Comme prévu par les accords de paix,
les Russes se dédommagent en nature
et démantèlent l'industrie allemande.
Des usines entières sont dépecées
et amenées en Union soviétique
pour être remontées.
En face, les Américains,
eux, reconstruisent.
Comme ils l'avaient promis
avec le plan Marshall,
les Américains ont donné
à l'Allemagne 16 milliards de dollars.
Nous de notre côté,
nous n'avons rien donné,
mais nous n'étions pas en mesure
de donner quoi que ce soit.
Nous ne pouvions pas rivaliser.
À l'ouest,
la vie reprend progressivement
tandis que le secteur Est
de Berlin reste à l'abandon.
Les Américains voudraient aller plus loin
et entreprendre de vastes réformes
afin de relancer l'économie allemande.
Staline s'y oppose.
Il veut maintenir un statu quo.
Ce que Staline veut,
c'est, qu'il y ait
un niveau de misère comparable
des deux cotés de Berlin
et que les Berlinois de l'Ouest isolés,
finissent par tomber
sous l'influence des Allemands de l'Est.
Cette enclave capitaliste
au milieu d'une mer communiste,
qu'est l'Allemagne de l'Est,
ce n'est pas supportable.
Pour sortir de l'impasse,
les Occidentaux ne voient
qu'une solution : fusionner leurs zones.
Voilà qui provoquera,
à n'en pas douter, la colère de Staline.
Jusqu'à quel point ?
Le généralissime
pourrait-il déclencher une guerre ?
Avant d'agir,
les Occidentaux ont besoin d'informations.
Et pour cela,
il n'existe qu'un seul moyen,
l'espionnage.
Seulement, en ce début de guerre froide,
les services secrets américains
sont, pour ainsi dire, inexistants.
Il est, d'ailleurs, intéressant de noter
que pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
en 1942,
l'administration Roosevelt a créé
un service de renseignement qui est l'OSS,
et que ce service
de renseignement cesse son activité
à la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale en 1945.
Donc entre 1945 et 1947,
les États-Unis n'ont pas de service
de renseignement en tant que tel.
À l'été 1947,
Truman décide donc de créer
une nouvelle agence de renseignement
qui, bientôt, sera connue
dans le monde entier : la CIA.
Henry Hillenkoetter,
un ancien amiral est nommé à sa tête.
Hillenkoetter a
la lourde tâche de recruter
et de former
des espions en toute hâte.
Le problème, c'est qu'il faut trouver
des espions parlant russe
et à part les Russes eux-mêmes,
il n'y a pas grand monde.
Pour cet ancien agent
des services secrets britanniques,
cela posait de graves difficultés.
Le problème, c'était de savoir
jusqu'où on pouvait faire confiance
à quelqu'un qui était russe de naissance
dans le cas de secrets importants.
parce qu'on n'avait jamais
la garantie que dans le même temps,
il ne travaillerait pas aussi
en même temps pour les Russes.
Hillenkoetter part alors au plus pressé.
En pragmatique,
c'est chez les ennemis
d'il y a quelques mois
qu'il va recruter ses espions.
Reinhardt Gehlen,
un ancien nazi ex-chef des renseignements
à l'Est dans la Wehrmacht,
est recyclé par la CIA.
Gehlen connaît très bien
le monde communiste.
Il va devenir le cerveau de
l'espionnage américain en Allemagne.
Par son entremise, des centaines
d'anciens nazis entrent à la CIA.
Les Américains
n'ont pas le moindre état d'âme.
La seule chose qui compte pour Truman,
c'est de barrer la route à Staline.
Le ciel a changé.
La guerre froide, l'ennemi,
ce n'était pas l'Allemagne,
c'est l'Union soviétique,
limite, prendre les gens qui sont
extrêmement anticommunistes.
Bien sûr, les anciens nazis sont
forcément très très anticommunistes.
Donc là, on est dans
la realpolitik complète.
Face à la CIA,
les services secrets russes du GRU
et du KGB sont également très actifs.
Ils ont une longueur d'avance
car leurs services de renseignement
existent depuis
la Première Guerre mondiale.
Berlin va devenir
la capitale de l'espionnage.
Dans la rue,
dans les administrations,
dans l'armée,
partout, se cachent des espions.
Tous, quels que soient leur camp,
ont le même objectif qui est de
déchiffrer les plans de l'adversaire
pour le prendre de vitesse.
L'espionnage,
c'était un nouveau style de guerre
dans lequel
on n'avait pas besoin de pistolet.
On pénétrait au cœur
du système de pensée de l'ennemi.
Comme Truman le leur avait demandé,
Gehlen et ses hommes cherchent à savoir
quelle serait la réaction de Staline
si les Occidentaux
fusionnaient leur zone à Berlin.
À la fin du printemps 1948,
les espions allemands
pensent enfin avoir la réponse.
Le 9 juin,
Hillenkoetter prévient
alors Truman par télégramme.
D'après le patron de la CIA,
si les Occidentaux
regroupaient leur zone d'occupation,
voila comment Staline réagirait.
L'URSS fera probablement en sorte
de mettre des bâtons
dans les roues des Occidentaux
à Berlin et partout ailleurs
où elle le pourra en Allemagne,
mais sans recourir à la force.
C'est le feu vert que
les Occidentaux attendaient.
Quatre jours après
le télégramme d'Hillenkoetter,
Américains,
Britanniques et Français créent
une nouvelle monnaie dans leur zone,
le Deutsche Mark.
Pour Staline,
cette monnaie, symbole du capitalisme,
est une provocation.
Il doit marquer le coup.
Comme les espions allemands
l'avaient anticipé,
le généralissime décide alors
de représailles économiques.
Le 24 juin 1948,
il fait couper toutes les
voies d'approvisionnement de Berlin-Ouest.
Les routes qui relient l'Allemagne de
l'Ouest à Berlin-Ouest sont bloquées.
Deux millions et demi
de Berlinois sont pris au piège.
Sans vivres,
ils ne pourront pas tenir longtemps.
À Washington,
une partie de son état major
pousse Truman à réagir par la force.
Le président américain
choisit une autre option.
Ravitailler Berlin par les airs.
Il ne voulait pas déclencher
une autre guerre avec les Soviétiques.
C'était même
la dernière chose qu'il voulait.
Mais il ne voulait pas
non plus apparaître faible
et montrer que nous ne réagissions pas.
Car si vous laissiez
les Soviétiques bloquer Berlin
ensuite,
ils feraient la même chose ailleurs.
Je ne crois pas que l'idée
du pont aérien ait été la sienne,
mais il l'a acceptée
car elle avait du sens.
Quatre jours après le début du blocus,
d'énormes avions cargos américains
et britanniques survolent Berlin.
Dans leurs entrailles,
des tonnes de vivres et de matériel
et les fameux CARE package.
Ces paquets,
conditionnés par l'ONG américaine CARE,
contiennent
tout ce qu'il faut pour survivre.
Bacon, margarine,
œufs en poudre, chocolat.
Le goût de l'Amérique.
Ce que Staline
n'avait pas du tout imaginé,
c'est que les Américains, les Anglais
et les Français réunis avaient les moyens
de maintenir pendant 11 mois
un approvisionnement de Berlin-Ouest
au rythme de 6 000 tonnes par jour.
C'est-à-dire que chaque jour,
sur les trois aérodromes de Berlin,
il y a un avion
qui atterrit toutes les 30 secondes.
Durant un an,
les Berlinois vont vivre
au rythme des avions
qui se relaient jour et nuit
au-dessus de leurs têtes.
Malgré l'aide américaine,
le quotidien reste difficile.
Pour tenir le coup,
chacun se débrouille.
On voit apparaître
des semeurs en pleine ville.
Les légumes, bientôt,
poussent au milieu du bitume.
Pour se chauffer aussi,
c'est le système D.
Les américains
n'envoient pas suffisamment de charbon,
alors les Berlinois
prennent le bois là ou il le trouve.
Les arbres sont déracinés.
Plus aucun banc
dans la ville n'a encore de planches.
Sur les marchés,
on échange tout ce qui est possible.
Manteaux, sacs, chaussures.
Les Berlinois manquent de tout,
mais ils tiennent bon.
Les Américains, eux aussi,
sont déterminés à tenir coûte que coûte.
Et comme Gehlen l'avait prévu,
Staline ne donne pas l'ordre
d'abattre les avions américains.
Il n'était pas prêt à faire la guerre car
les Américains avaient la bombe atomique.
L'Union soviétique ne pouvait pas
supporter une nouvelle guerre
alors que nous avions
déjà eu plus de 20 millions de morts
lors de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Comprenant qu'il a perdu
la partie de bras de fer,
le 12 mai 1949,
Staline lève le blocus.
Partout dans Berlin-Ouest,
c'est une explosion de joie.
Pour le leader communiste,
l'échec est cuisant.
Le petit boutiquier du Missouri
a fait plier l'homme
le plus craint de la planète.
Dans ses mémoires,
Truman se réjouit.
Il sait que dans la course
qui l'oppose à Staline,
il vient de marquer un point décisif.
Le blocus avait vivement retourné
les Allemands contre le communisme.
L'Allemagne,
qui avait attendu passivement de voir
vers qui elle jetterait
son dévolu pour l'avenir,
se tournait à présent
vers la cause des nations occidentales.
Ça fait exactement
l'inverse de ce que voulait Staline
qui voulait toujours semer
la zizanie entre les alliés.
Ça scelle la réconciliation et l'amitié
entre le peuple allemand
et les Américains, bien entendu.
Ils sont devenus extrêmement populaires.
Ce sont les hommes
qui ont permis la survie de Berlin-Ouest.
Quinze jours après la levée du blocus,
les Occidentaux créent
la République fédérale d'Allemagne.
Les Soviétiques ripostent avec
la République démocratique d'Allemagne.
Cette fois, les alliés d'hier sont
officiellement devenus des ennemis.
À la Maison Blanche,
Kennan est terrifié.
Visionnaire, il écrit:
"En fin de compte,
notre politique sur le continent
nous emmène vers une situation
où il n'y a que trois solutions :
un effondrement soviétique,
une désintégration
de notre propre position
ou une terrible guerre".
Cette menace d'une terrible guerre pèse
chaque jour un peu plus sur le monde.
Staline n'a pas digéré
le camouflet du blocus.
Il cherche à reprendre le dessus.
À force d'efforts,
il va, une nouvelle fois,
parvenir à renverser la situation.
Le 29 août 1949,
à la stupeur des Occidentaux,
les Russes font exploser
une bombe atomique au Kazakhstan.
Les informations de Fuchs
et de ses camarades infiltrés à Los Alamos
ont fini par porter leurs fruits.
Les services de renseignement
soviétiques nous ont aidés
à accélérer la création de
la bombe atomique en Union soviétique
et ils nous ont permis
d'économiser beaucoup de moyens.
Nos scientifiques
pensent que les informations
reçues par nos services secrets
nous ont permis de raccourcir
le temps de la création de la bombe
de dix à cinq ans.
Pour Truman, la surprise est grande.
Jamais il n'aurait imaginé que
les Soviétiques, ruinés par la guerre,
mettent aussi peu de temps
à élaborer l'arme nucléaire.
Staline, lui, se sent à nouveau fort.
L'Union soviétique
est redevenue l'égale des États-Unis.
Le monde entre dans
l'équilibre de la terreur.
Cette guerre froide,
Raymond Aron
l'a très bien résumée
en disant que c'est une guerre impossible,
impossible parce qu'elle serait atomique,
paix improbable.
Guerre impossible, paix improbable.
Les conflits, en effet,
ne vont pas tarder à éclater.
Mais ils resteront locaux
et se feront par puissances interposées.
Car jamais le sang entre Américains
et Soviétiques ne devra couler.
Au risque de provoquer
un embrasement généralisé.
C'est dans un petit pays,
que bien peu de Russes et d'Américains
seraient situés sur la carte,
que le premier de ces conflits
postdeuxième guerre mondiale va éclater.
La Corée.
Depuis 1945, la Corée,
qui appartenait au Japon,
est occupée de part et d'autre
du 38ème parallèle.
Au sud, les Américains.
Au nord, les Soviétiques.
Depuis cette époque,
Kim Il-sung,
le leader nord coréen communiste,
cherche à réunifier son pays.
À plusieurs reprises,
il a demandé de l'aide à Staline.
Le soviétique a toujours refusé.
Pourtant, ce 12 janvier 1950,
le généralissime change d'avis.
À cause d'une toute petite phrase
prononcée par Dean Acheson,
le secrétaire d'état américain,
Ce jour-là, dans son discours sur
les ambitions militaires américaines,
Acheson a écrit :
" Notre périmètre défensif s'étend
des îles Aléoutiennes au Japon ",
" en passant par
Ryukyu et les Philippines ".
Il a oublié la Corée.
C'est la bêtise à ne pas faire.
Il y avait Taïwan,
Tokyo, il y avait les Philippines,
il y avait tout,
mais il a oublié la Corée,
ce n'est pas malin.
C'est curieux pour quelqu'un
d'aussi avisé que Dean Acheson.
Enfin, il a fait la bourde
et ça a été pris par Staline
comme un encouragement.
Et il s'est dit qu'après tout,
les Américains
sont peut-être redevenus mous.
Staline donne alors son feu vert à
Kim Il-sung pour passer à l'action.
Le 25 juin 1950, à 4 heures du matin,
l'armée nord-coréenne franchit
le 38ème parallèle.
Truman, en week-end
dans sa maison du Missouri,
est aussitôt prévenu.
Le président américain
n'a alors pas l'ombre d'une hésitation.
Il faut répondre par la force.
Dans ses mémoires, il se souvient.
Si un tel scénario n'était pas
empêché en Corée,
cela signifiait le début d'une
troisième guerre mondiale.
Car ce sont des incidents similaires
qui avaient provoqué
la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
Les Américains ne s'attendaient pas
à une attaque en Corée.
Ils n'y ont pratiquement aucune troupe.
Les Nord-coréens progressent
avec une facilité déconcertante
et s'emparent de Séoul
en moins d'une semaine.
Truman est extrêmement préoccupé.
Comment tout cela va-t-il finir ?
Le président écrit à sa femme.
J'espère que je n'aurai pas à donner
l'ordre de lâcher notre arme terrible.
Truman n'aura pas besoin
de se servir de la bombe atomique,
car il peut compter sur un homme,
le général MacArthur
Grand héros
de la guerre dans le Pacifique,
il est chargé d'administrer le Japon.
Il connaît bien l'Asie
et c'est un tacticien hors pair.
En quelques mois,
MacArthur parvient à reprendre
l'avantage sur les communistes.
En novembre 1950,
les Américains ont presque
entièrement envahi la Corée du Nord.
Ils sont tout près
de la frontière chinoise
La Guerre froide menace alors
de devenir très chaude
car depuis 1949,
la Chine voisine est devenue communiste.
Mao dépêche alors
500 000 volontaires chinois
pour porter secours
à ses frères Nord-Coréens.
Là aussi, on remarque, finalement,
la prudence de Mao dans ce conflit.
Qu'il ne souhaite pas
intervenir en tant qu'État
et qu'il utilise cet artifice
des volontaires chinois
pour, en quelque sorte,
intervenir officieusement.
Il y a, certes,
d'une façon empirique,
non théorisée,
une maîtrise de la guerre froide.
Chacun avance,
mais chacun
fait en sorte que tout soit maîtrisé
pour que la guerre froide
ne devienne pas
une guerre générale,
mondiale et nucléaire
Pour Truman, cette situation
particulièrement tendue depuis des mois
est épuisante psychologiquement.
Dans son journal, il écrit :
quel enfer d'être le président de
la nation la plus puissante de la Terre !
Je préfèrerais être
le premier dans mon village.
Le président américain
n'appelle plus la Maison Blanche
autrement que " la prison blanche ".
En Corée, le conflit s'enlise
et c'est un événement totalement
inattendu qui va mettre fin à la guerre.
Staline va disparaître.
1er mars 1953,
Datcha de Kountsevo,
dans les environs de Moscou.
Staline vit désormais ici en reclus.
L'homme qui fait
trembler la planète entière
s'est enfermé dans un délire paranoïaque.
Il a peur d'être assassiné.
Ce soir-là,
lorsque Staline se couche,
il a beaucoup bu.
Dans la nuit,
il est victime d'une hémorragie cérébrale.
Pendant dix heures,
il agonise sans que personne
n'ose pousser la porte de sa chambre.
Chacun a bien trop peur
des représailles possibles.
Il a agonisé tout seul.
Et tous ceux qui auraient pu le soigner,
notamment son médecin, est en prison.
Il aurait pu s'en remettre.
Quand les vieux acolytes arrivent,
les Khrouchtchev, les Beria,
les Vorochilov, les Malenkov
et tous ces gens-là,
ils n'osent rien faire.
Car ça pourrait leur être reproché,
ils font venir des médecins,
mais les médecins ont peur.
Ils n'osent même pas faire un diagnostic
parce que le KGB est derrière eux.
Et il leur dit :
camarade fais attention à ce que tu écris
et fais attention à ce que tu découvres.
Faute de soins appropriés.
Après quatre jours d'agonie,
le 5 mars 1953,
Joseph Staline s'éteint.
Dès que la nouvelle a été connue,
cinq millions de personnes
affluent vers Moscou.
Tous veulent voir la dépouille de celui
qui a eu droit de vie et de mort sur eux
pendant un quart de siècle.
Beaucoup de gens
qui détestaient Staline ont dit :
Dieu soit loué.
Il a enfin crevé.
Beaucoup d'autres
voyaient en lui un genre de dieu
et ils étaient abasourdis par le fait
que leur dieu puisse être mortel.
Le troisième sentiment qui dominait
et qui valait pour tout le monde était
"qu'est ce qui va arriver maintenant ?"
Le monde entier est sous le choc.
Alors que Molotov et les proches
de Staline portent son cercueil,
chacun pense à la suite.
À Moscou,
Londres ou Washington,
les peuples espèrent
que la disparition du dictateur soviétique
mettra un terme aux tensions.
Les espérances seront vite déçues.
Huit années de conflit permanent
et larvées entre
l'Amérique et l'Union soviétique
ont à ce point façonné le monde,
qu'il est impossible
de faire subitement machine arrière.
La guerre froide initiée par Staline
et Truman continuera de régir le monde
et de faire trembler
les hommes pendant près de 40 ans.